j'ouvre notre second débat un débat de
société volontairement décalé de
l'actualité du jour consacré au aux
nuisances au dangers des réseaux sociaux
notamment pour les plus jeunes 40 États
américains ont porté plainte contre méta
la maison mère de Facebook et Instagram
en l'accusant notamment de nuire à la
santé mentale des enfants et adolescents
l'Union européenne a également ouvert
une enquête contre TikTok et YouTube
mais peut-on vraiment réguler les
réseaux sociaux avant d'en débattre
première réponse en image grâce à Jérôme
Rabier
ils sont devenus des outils du quotidien
qu'une immense majorité de français
utilise massivement les réseaux sociaux
font désormais partie de nos vies avec
leurs atouts et leurs défauts pour
lutter contre ces derniers les états
cherchent désormais à encadrer leurs
pratiqu en France un projet de loi pour
les réguler et sur le point d'être
définitivement voté dans la ligée d'un
texte européen qui leur impose de rendre
des des règles extrêmement
contraignantes aux réseaux sociaux il
leur oblige de retirer les à retirer les
contenus illicites sur leur plateforme
mais aussi à tenir compte de la manière
dont leurs algorithmes viennent
parasiter la sécurité publique le
discours civique et la santé de leurs
utilisateur un projet de loi qui vise
aussi un équilibre entre la fonction de
porte-voie utile et les dérives
constatées protection des données
personnelles la protection de la vie
privée la lutte contre les infractions
pénales bah ça peut permettre d'avoir
une régulation un encadrement qui soit
respectueux à la fois la liberté sur
Internet mais notamment la liberté
d'expression mais aussi qui permett de
garantir le respect des droits des des
citoyens de l'Union européenne Emmanuel
Macron lui-même après avoir incité les
plateformes à se renforcer sur la
modération veut passer à la vitesse
supérieure organisant la semaine
dernière une réunion internationale sur
la lutte contre la haine en ligne le
locataire de l'Élysée ne s'est pas privé
de critiquer les grands réseaux ABS dont
Twitter et Facebook je considère que
quand des entreprises qui s'étaient
engagé nous avaient dit des choses
formidables s'organisent pour pas être
là et font pas ce qu'elles ont dit
qu'elle le ferit la
confiance se réduit surtout quand
d'autres continuent de faire le boulot
main dans la main l'État français et
l'Union européenne rappelle
régulièrement à l'ordre ces géants du
numérique sur les règles à respecter
quand ils s'adressent aux utilisateurs
européens sans que les effets se fassent
réellement sentir sur le développement
de ces plateformes mondiales des
entreprises plus puissantes que certains
états peut-on encore réguler les réseaux
sociaux comment se protéger de la
profusion d'imagees d'information de
contenu culturel sur Internet on en
débat avec Bruno Patino bonsoir bonsoir
bienvenue vous êtes le président d'Arté
auteur de ce livre submersion publié aux
éditions grassè et notamment ce livre
qui nous a donné envie d'organiser ce
débat Alexandra borquio Fontain bonsoir
bonsoir bienvenue à vous vous êtes
sénatrice LR des Alpes Maritimes
rapportrice de la proposition de loi qui
vise à lutter contre la n en ligne qui a
été promulgué le le 7 juillet dernier
Michel Guérin bonsoir et bienvenue vous
êtes rédacteur en chef au monde euh vous
publiez notamment une chronique culturel
hebdomadaire et j'accueille Mathieu
croissandau euh enfin j'accueille non je
salue de nouveau Mathieu croissandau
hisorialiste politique euh dans votre
livre Bruno patinau submersion vous
décrivez notre monde en parler en
parlant d'une société des Nuces baissées
euh j'aime bien VO il faut pas réduire
le livre à cette expression mais elle
nous a frappé on est tous comme ça et
c'est vrai un peu penché sur nos
smartphones est-ce que c'est pas trop
tard démarré sur le la difficulté de
réguler ses réseaux sociaux non c'est
jamais trop tard enfin je on y reviendra
c'est vrai que je je me dis quand même
alors je suis je suis pas médecin et
évidemment mais nos attitudes
corporelles ont changé les nucs sont
baissés on a des casque dans les
oreilles on a des tendinites au pouce et
ça il y a un nom particulier nos
attitudes aussi elles ont changé on a
l'habitude d'être sursollicité Acher
laattention haché et autre mais non ça
n'est pas trop tard moi je je j'essaie
dans le livre mais mais on va parler
après du du sujet mais de de dire bon
c'est un on a vécu pendant très
longtemps avec on va dire une difficulté
d'accès aux images au messages au textes
à l'information au divertissement à la
culture tout d'un coup on a un outil qui
arrive et qui est une profusion
absolument incroyable de messages de
texte et d'images de mise en réseau
aussi on voit bien qu'on a les trois
étapes la copie ultime la viralisation
totale maintenant pratiquement la
production infinie cette abondance là
est devenue une sorte de problème mais
et et on y reviendra je crois pas qu'il
soit trop tard parce que encore une fois
si on part du principe qu'un changement
aussi majeur a eu lieu en 1455 avec
l'invention de l'imprimerie si nous
avions fait un débat évidemment
technologiquement c'était pas possible
mais un débat de cette sorte 30 ou 40
ans après l'invention de l'imprimerie on
aurait parlé libel panflé les guerres de
religion qui arrivent la polarisation
social qui arrive et on se serait dit
est-ce qu'il n'est pas trop tard or
quelques décennies mais c'est le temps
de réguler après l'invention de
l'imprimerie il y a la philosophie des
Lumières la démocratie moderne qui
arrive donc c'est le temps d'agir en
tout cas c'est vraiment le temps d'agir
par la régulation cert par beaucoup
d'autres choses aussi mais c'est le
temps d'agir oui un un chiffre pour pour
illustrer ce que sont devenus réseaux
sociaux notamment et je vais me tourner
vers vous vers les plus jeunes d'entre
nous 67 % des 8 10 ans sont déjà
présents sur ces réseaux sociaux c'est
l'association i enfance qui nous dit ça
dans une enquête publiée euh au mois de
juin dernier et ce chiffre il a plus que
doublé en 2 ans Alexandra Bruc Fontain
la la haine en ligne c'est l'un des
danger c'est pas le seul hein mais qui
qui nous guettete qui guette nos enfants
euh je je vais commencer sur la loi
tiens quelle elle change quoi votre loi
parce qu'on se pose la question de
qu'est-ce qu'on peut faire est-ce qu'il
est trop tard est-ce qu'on peut encore
réguler elle change quoi cette loi alors
j'ai été donc rapporteur d'une
proposition loi d'un collègue député
justement qui visé en fait à instaurer
une majorité numérique on a estimé en
tant que législateur que 15 ans était un
âge justement où on pouvait avoir en
tout cas assez de discernement pour
pouvoir s'inscrire seul et on a estimé
que en DESS ça de de 15 ans il fallait
l'autorisation d'un des deux parents
cette proposition de loi qui a été donc
votée et la loi a été promulgué pose un
certain nombre de difficultés d'abord
techniqu puisque c aux plateformes
eux-mêmes d'effectuer cette vérification
d'âge c'est assez complexe la signifie
qu'il faut demander aux parents la carte
d'identité également pour les enfants et
puis prouver aussi que ce sont les
parents donc transmettent le livret de
famille donc beaucoup de données à à
rechercher de la part des plateformes
lors des audition ça on se dit ça doit
pas vraiment être appliqué ah bah pas
vraiment alors c'est assez récent quand
on a effectué ce travail on a auditionné
comme vous vous en doutez la plupart des
plateformes dont les logos apparaissent
sur vos écrans qui bien sûr n'étaient
pas les plus enjoués à mettre en place
ce dispositif mais il pouvait que
reconnaître qu'aujourd'hui à un moment
donné il n'est jamais trop tard pour
réguler à mon sens on on le fait bien
tard mais il faut quand même le faire on
peut pas le laisser justement quand on
voit toutes les conséquences sur la
santé mentale de de et je je rejoins
tout à fait les les propos du président
d'aré justement toutes les conséquences
psychologiques que peuvent avoir les les
les les les les mineurs et les jeunes
enfants sur la la diffusion de tous ces
contenus et cette addiction hein
aujourd'hui vous parlez des chiffres du
nombre donc tout le problème tout le
problème revient du fait qu'on a un
smartphone de plus en plus jeune euh
donc aujourd'hui 46 % des 610 ans ont un
smartphone 64 % des 101 ans sont inscrit
sur un réseau seal parce que aussi c'est
la mode et que si on n'est pas inscrit
sur certaines plateformes et ben on est
plus dans le coup donc en tout cas voilà
et bien sûr ces plateformes sont
addictives et engendre des conséquences
assez dramatiques Mathie pardon mais
pourquoi ça marcherait ce coup-ci ça
fait je pas 50 ans que le porno est
interdit au moins de 18 ans ça fait 20
ans ou 25 ans qu'il existe sur Internet
et tout le monde s'en plain tout le
monde dit faut pas que les enfants et
accès au porno ils y ont toujours accès
donc alors ça c'est c'est un un énorme
sujet celui de la des contenus et de la
diffusion des contenus pornographiques
euh depuis 2020 il y a une loi qui
interdit les sites pornographiques de
diffuser des contenu aux mineurs avec
trois autres collègues sénatrices on a
produit un rapport qui s'appelle porno
l'enfer du décor où on on parle des
dérives c'est un rapport assez complet
des dérives de l'industrie
pornographique sur tout un tas de sujets
dont la diffusion aux mineurs et on
demande justement l'application de cette
loi donc actuellement on a énormément
échangé avec le le mineur pour l'instant
il y a une expérimentation qui est mis
en place avec un site très connu
justement qui devrait vérifier C dou
pour faireat sur le porno mais c c'est
sans succès pour le porno donc au cur de
notre débat sur la capacité des États à
réguler ou non intervenir point aussi
c'est que depuis des années on nous dit
que les écrans sont hyper dangereux pour
les enfants mais carrément certains sont
en psychiatrique c'est dramatique et
puis y a une dernière étude il y a
quelques il a à peine hier je crois
avanier qui de médecins c'est pas si
grave que ça donc c'est tout le problème
aussi de sair qu'est-ce qu'on va croire
qu'est-ce que moi je pense c'est plutôt
très dangereux mais quand je lis dis
hier je me dis ou là mais alors quel
effet ça sur les gens les parents et
cetera quoi ce où est où faut mettre le
curseur quoi ça l'air oui c'est vrai
qu'on a on a des des informations ou des
injonctions un peu contradictoires on a
appris je crois que c'était aujourd'hui
ou hier enfin j'ai lu ça en tout cas
aujourd'hui hier que la Suède revenait
au au manuel papier après être passé au
tout numérique pour dans dans ces écoles
Bruno Patino vouliez réagir oui non
parce que si on regarde bien la la
régulation des plateformes en fait il y
a me semble-t-il et puis après je
répondrai peut-être sur le porno il y a
il y a deux choses il y a ce sur quoi on
peut agir et il y a ce sur quoi on
n'agira pas donc il vaut mieux apprendre
ce sur quoi on peut agir
euh c'est le fonctionnement interne de
ces plateformes qui pousseent
effectivement à la dépendance et on va
dire à la polarisation on va pas revenir
sur ce qu'on appelle l'économie de la
tension mais l'économie le modèle
économique de ces plateformes qui pousse
effectivement qui édite par la de voie
algorithmique qui ordonne les messages
de façon à ce qu'ils soient les plus
émotionnels possibles les plus efficaces
économiquement dans la tension possible
provoque à la fois des effets de
dépendance et des effets de polarisation
publique donc ça on le voit on le
connaît quand même j'entend bien ce fait
ça sert à rien mais malgré tout le DSA
on y reviendra peut-être en Europe la
responsabilité algorithmique que
certains états américain essayent de
mettre en place vous avez parlé des des
des attaques contre méta qui sont en
train de faire aux États-Unis donc là on
voit qu'on va dans cette dans dans cette
direction là après il y a deux autres
facteurs sur lequel on ne peut pas
revenir et qui sont quand même aussi
relativement problématiques et là il
faut apprendre c'est çaend le premier
c'est que un réseau social et c'est pour
les les générations les plus anciennes
ça ça qu'il est nouveau malaxe et
mélange tous les types de messages donc
c'est un réseau qui n'est pas promoteur
d'un contexte donné vous avez de
l'information des blagues de la
désinformation de l'amitié tout ça
voisine et donc de la haine évidemment
et donc tout ça voisine et donc ça n'est
pas le réseau qui vous donne le contexte
contra un journal une émission de télé
un bistro ou ailleurs ils s'en défendent
même ils veulent surtout pas cette
responsabilé et donc apprendre cette
absence de contexte qui ne vous est pas
donné par par par les choses est déjà
très compliqué la deuxième chose c'est
qu'en fait le réseau vous pensez qu'il
vous met en relation avec quelqu'un mais
il vous met en relation avec on va dire
une approximation de cette personne
c'est-à-dire que en gros vous n'êtes pas
vraiment face à la personne vous êtes
face à une approximation calculée de
cette personne 14 signe ça fait pas une
personne une réaction émotionnelle ça
n'est pas une personne et donc vous
réduisez et donc c'est pas un hasard si
l'année dernière une des requêtes les
plus importantes sur Google qui a été
faite c'est comment faire pour me faire
des amis alors que normalement là vous
voyez toutes les tout ce que vous avez
montré ici comme comme logo c'est des
outils qui vous disent vous avez vous
avez des tonnes d'amis vous avez des
nouveaux amis par jour et cetera et
pourant on n jamais été aussi nombreux
connectés on sont jamais aussi seul quoi
on pour bien moi je pense
qu'effectivement on est passé de la
masse à la multitude et que la multitude
souvent elle rime avec solitude et c'est
ça qui nous arrive maintenant sur le
port
j'entends sur on n arrive pas mais en
réalité on voit les mesures de limite
d'âge quand même se mettre en place il y
a des moyens techniqu aussi il y a des
moyens techniques qui arrivent mais
après on sait bien qu'un des moyens
techniques qui est à l'étude aujourd'hui
pose un autre problème c'est celui de la
reconnaissance facial c'est vous avez
des méthodes aujourd'hui qui sont
envisagé en disant bah voilà les sites
pornographiques s'ils veulent ne pas
être à un moment donné vous avez deux
actions en fait la reconnaissance
faciale mais en terme de liberté
qu'est-ce qu'on fait oui non ou
l'identité un/ers
un/ers et puis par ailleurs aussi ces
réseaux là vivent en partie de la
publicité du modèle payant donc on a
quand même quelques outils poss
possiblees alors si on essaie évidemment
de pas être caricatureau dans ce débat
on peut dire aussi que Michel Guerin les
les réseaux sociaux ils peuvent décider
de du du succès d'un d'un produit
culturel il y a une très bonne histoire
à raconter en ce moment qui concerne le
cinéma et qui concerne le film
l'adaptation du livre de Vanessa
springora le consentement racontez-nous
ce qui est en train de se passer sur le
réseau social TikTok ça date il y a
quand même 3 semaines déjà mais ça ça ne
descend pas tellement c'estàd qu'au
départ le film la première semaine
marche pas pas bien et fait 40000
entrées c'est un film d'arrêt d'essè le
public est plutôt âgé urbain aisé et
c'est voilà on a connu ça 1000 fois OK
et à partir du 2è weekend il se passe un
truc très très bizarre les patrons de
salle vont arriver des jeunes qui n'ont
jamais vu et ces jeunes euh souent
viennent de milieu plutôt modestes et
viennent de banlieu et il viennent en
masse ils viennent avec des copains des
copines parfois leurs parents et sont
essentiellement des filles et là le film
il se passe pour le film quelque chose
qu'on ne voit jamais c'est-à-dire que la
2uxème semaine il double quasiment le
nombre d'entrées la troisème semaine il
triple et et on est passé en gros de
bientôt on va être à on est on vient
dépasser les 500000 entrées ils vont
sûrement faire 600000 et cetera et
cetera et et et c'est pourquoi parce que
euh sur TikTok euh la mayonnaise a pris
oui al elle prend pas toujours on croit
qu'il suffit qu'un distributeur enfin je
pense QUETIN conna ça mieux que moi il
suffit qu'un distributeur ou un
producteur fasse de la pub
met des choses sur non pas du tout c'est
il faut tant que les jeunes ne s'en
emparent pas ça marche pas quoi pourquoi
ça il empar je pense que le sujet lié
alors donc donc lié au consentement lié
à
l'emprise pour les je pense que les
filles connaissent ça assez bien et et
depuis très longtemps sur plein de
moments de leur vie de leur journée même
ça c'est important une identification à
l'actrice évidente la fille a 23 ans
joue le rôle d'une fille de 14 ans or
les gens qui vont en salle les jeunes
ils ont entre 15 et 20 ans et souvent il
avant et après la ou il se filme avant
et avant ils sont un pe un peu rigolards
genre on va voir un film qu' on nirait
jamais voir si on avait pas vu sur
TikTok il fallait y aller et puis après
ça rigole plus du tout et pour une
raison qu'on peut imaginer voilà donc y
il y a des on pe donner des exemples de
livres passé alors de musique c'est très
connu aussi et donc ça qu'il y a une
prescription culturelle total fait
nouvelle qui vient s'ajouter à une
prescription plus classique et voilà et
personne ne se demande où ça va aller
alors ça ça partie de la submersion moi
que je TR intéressant par rapport au
livre de Bruno Patino c'est comment une
submersion j'en dire
naturelle mais qui qui est déjà ancienne
il y a 20 ans c'estàd classique c'estàd
on a de plus en plus de films de plus en
plus de musique de plus en plus de
livres enfin c'est c'est exponentiel et
cetera alors que le public n'a pas
augmenté ça c'est très important se
double maintenant d' submersion
numérique et et quand les deux centre
choc où ça va qu'est-ce qui se passe et
c'est voilà et c'est c'est c'est assez
affolant en même temps alors ça on y
reviendra on y consacrera la dernière
partie de l'émission évidemment mais je
voudrais quand même qu'on reste quand
même sur ce thème de de de notre
capacité mais ça se rejoint de toute
façon à se protéger des réseaux sociaux
on a je je je le donnais en lancement je
vais redonner cette information 40 États
américains qui portent plainte contre
MTA c'est la maison mère entre autres he
de Facebook et et Instagram plainte en
justice accusation de nuire à la la
santé mentale des jeunes je cite les les
la plainte d'avoir conçu ces
applications notamment Instagram pour
être aussi addictif que possible bon
c'est pas vraiment une découverte je
vous propose d'écouter la porte-parole
d'une association américaine alors elle
rentre un peu plus dans le détail elle
accuse de Instagram d'aggraver les
complexes physiques de nombreuses jeunes
filles nous sommes ici aujourd'hui parce
que le modèle économique de Facebook est
pourri jusqu'à la moelle et la preuve en
est ce qu'il fait à nos enfants Facebook
sait qu'il aux enfants ces recherches
menées en interne que la lanceuse
d'alerte Francis Hogan a exposé il y a
quelques semaines montre qu'Instagram
aggrave les complexe physique d'une
fille sur TR nous avons également mené
nos propres recherches sur Instagram et
nous avons trouvé sur la plateforme plus
de 45 millions de posts sur les troubles
alimentaires le le risque pour le ces
jeunes en souffrance Alexandra borquio
Fontain c'est quoi c'est de rester
enfermé dans une espèce de de bulles
cognitive néfaste négative oui
c'estàdire que d'imaginer que ce qui se
passe sur les réseaux sociaux c'est la
réalité et c'est vrai que sur Instagram
quand on on fait passer le fil
d'actualité qu'on et surtout pour les
jeunes filles hein d'ailleurs ce sont
ell les principales cibles qui sont
victimes justement de de problèmes
cognitifs de problèmes assez graves
finalement qui les qui on dit même que
la moitié aurait des symptômes
dépressifs en passant plus de 5 heur par
jour sur les réseaux sociaux donc
évidemment beaucoup sur la question de
l'apparence physique bien sûr c'est pour
ça qu'il y a eu aussi des textes qui ont
qui qui qui étaient là pour rég aussi la
communication des influenceurs qui
faisaient de la promotion pour de la
chirurgie esthétique ou voilà tout
autour de la beauté donc de prendre des
jeunes filles ce sont des cibles faciles
on a toujours envie voilà de ressembler
à ces icônes alors peut-être qu'avant on
feuilletait des magazines et on avait
aussi envie de de de Ty ressembler mais
aujourd'hui il y a des vidéos
aujourd'hui ça va très loin sur
Instagram je voyais il y a pas longtemps
qu'il y avait des tutos pour comment
savoir comment s'injecter Sauto injecter
de l'acideonique dans le visage avec des
tutos sur Youtube enfin c'est il y a un
moment donné et voilà et tout ça se
diffuse sans régulation et c'est ce que
moi en tant que législateur en tout cas
j'essaie de de de de contribuer à mieux
encadrer mieux réguler parce qu'il y a
des véritables conséquences de santé et
social sur sur sur les jeunes et puis il
y a à peu près 46 % des adolescentes qui
qui me disait lors des auditions 46 %
d'an que j'avais interrogé qui me disait
qu'elle serait dévasté si on devait leur
interdire l'accès à un réseau social non
pas àe mais quelques jours ça en dit
long donc sur le caractère addictif et
sur les conséquences que peuvent avoir
c'est diffus oui c'est pas une
découverte bonop Patino mais
effectivement vous l'avez un peu évoqué
le modèle il est fait pour qu'on y passe
le plus ça moi moi je fais partie des
gens qui pensent pas qu'on doiv se
protéger des réseaux sociaux en revanche
fait partie des gens qui pensent qu'on
doit modifier le fonctionnement des
réseaux sociaux très fortement
c'est-à-dire que c'est plutôt chez eux
que les modifications doivent avoir lieu
et pas parce que c'est un outil de
socialisation vous l'avez parfaitement
dit aussi c'est un outil de partage de
socialisation de découverte et cetera
aller sur les causes et pas les
conséquences toutes les études toutes
les études montrent quand même c'est un
outil de socialisation
maintenant ce qui est mentionné
notamment Francis Hogen avait c'est une
ancienne salariée de
Facebook qui qui qui a fait ce qu'on
appelle les Facebook papers a montré des
études internes à MTA et notamment qui
parlait d'anorexie effectivement de de
la conséquence sur sur les plus fragiles
et parce que il faut bien voir si vous
voulez il y a les deux choses qu'on
disait c'est-à-dire que d'abord ces
réseaux vous mettent en lien avec une
caricature en fait Instagram c'est le
lieu du filtre donc on se met des
filtres alors quelque fois ça fait rire
quand on voit un un justiciable
américain qui arrive pas à enlever son
filtre de chat et qui parle au juge en
disant je suis désolé j'arrive pas
l'histoire est tout à fait vraie
j'arrive pas à cesser d'être un chat
donc ça c'est drôle quand vous avez un
filtre de chat mais tous les filtres qui
vous fait alors en ce moment vous voyez
sur Instagram même ce ce concours sur le
filtre presque négatif qui vous vieillit
et cetera donc c'est effectivement il y
a il y a ce côté j'allais dire de de de
dysmorphie perman
la personne avec laquelle on est en
train de discutero il y a même des
chirurgiens esthétiques qui vous dit
qu'il y a des gens maintenant qui
veulent ressembler à un filtre en fait
un filtre Instagram quand ils se font
mais je je la nature le fait que ces
messages soient présents sur les réseaux
est un problème pour moi le problème le
plus grave c'est que ces messages sont
structurellement accélérés sur ces
réseaux c'est-à-dire que les réseaux
dans leur fonctionnement économique ce
genre de message sont accélérés et
amplifiés donc ce sont les plus visi
réalité et donc ce système addictif il a
un impact extrêmement fort parce que les
réseaux ne sont pas neutres dans
l'organisation des messages même le
modèle économique qui on est bien
d'accord je pense que ce que vous disiez
sur la représentation physique ou
l'image de soi-même qui est déformé par
par les filtres le problème en ce qui
concerne l'anorexie c'est que ça vous
met des gamines de 14 ans ou de 15 ans
en contact avec des anorexiques et qui
nous pouch sur Instagram que des c'est
pas c'est pas des filtres c'est pas des
fausses choses c'est espèce de
compétition d'émulation dans la maîtrise
de soi-même et l'amaigrissement et il y
a un
côté le piège des algorithmes qui qui
qui qui fait qui fait plongerette bu
dans laquelle on on rrouve en c'est même
pas de la
fiction ESP de communauté qui célèbre ça
ça espèce de entre guillemets concours
le terme est pas pas peut-être mal venu
mais c'est un peu l'idée vous avez
évoqué le le DSA le digital service act
on va parler de de cette loi européenne
tout de suite grâce à Jonathan du Pr qui
pe nous rejoindre sur ce plateau euh re
bonsoir Jonathan alors c'est quoi ce DSA
dites-nous tout B alors le DSA Thomas et
ben c'est le digital services Act en bon
anglais c'est un règlement européen qui
est entré en vigueur il y a 2 mois et
qui é dicte un cadre un cadre très
strict avant toute chose pour les 19
géants de de l'Internet qui opèent dans
l'Union européenne c'est on quand on
parle de géant c'est plus de 45 millions
d'utilisateurs donc c'est quand même
assez considérable on ne les présente
plus hein c'est Facebook Instagram X qui
est l'ex Twitter ou encore YouTube alors
qu'est-ce qu'il y a dedans on va le on
va le voir en détail euh les trois
mesures phares euh c'est avant toute
autre chose l'obligation de retirer
promptement tout contenu qui pourrait
être illicite hein c'est-à-dire qu' ne
respecte pas les lois euh des pays de
l'Union européenne l'obligation de
transparence pour les algorithmes euh et
enfin il impose un audit indépendant à
ces plateformes qui est censé se se
tenir une fois par an sous l'autorité de
la Commission européenne et c'est une
législation qui est sans équivalent dans
le monde en tout cas le commissaire
européen qui a piloté ce ce projet
Thierry Breton c'est un français et ben
il s'en félicit il y a quelques semaines
écoutez-le il est vraiment temps pour
l'Europe pour nous de fixer nos propres
règles le DSA est là pour protéger la
liberté d'expression contre les
décisions
arbitraires et en même temps pour
protéger nos citoyens et nos démocraties
contre les contenus illégaux mes
services et moi-même seront désormais
très rigoureux pour vérifier que les
plateformes systémiques se conformment
au
DSA en d'autres termes Thomas si on veut
résumer ça comme ça l'Europe essaie de
siffler un petit peu la fin de la récrée
pour ces plateformes qui en cours de
très lourdes amendes jusqu'à 6 % de leur
chiffre d'affaires et on verra la
capacité à appliquer ou non ces amendes
et et quelles sanction ce règlement il a
déjà été utile on l'a vu dernièrement
avec l'attaque du ramas contre Israël
ouis effectivement et c'est même X qui
est la première plateforme à en faire
les frais
la plateformme elle a été étriée donc le
mois dernier par l'Union européenne pour
avoir inondé le web de contenu violent
et trompeur lors de l'attaque du Hamas
du 7 octobre vous le disiez ça a donné
lieu à une passe d'armes sur Twitter
justement entre Elon Musk le patron
Twitter X et le commissaire au marché
intérieur tiré breton qu'on vient
d'entendre une passe d'armes dont je
vous livre ces quelques mots merci de
dresser la liste des des violations
auxquelles vous faites allusion sur X à
té le le milliardaire américain Elon
Musk et Thierry Breton lui a répondu
tout aussi sec vous devez agir
rapidement avec diligence et objectivité
et retirer le contenu en question
lorsque cela est justifié lui dit-il à
la suite de cette affaire et bien x
pourrait s'exposer à ces fameuses
sanctions financières et est-ce que
cette loi européenne s'est appliquée
déjà appliqué à d'autres plateformes oui
et encore hier il y a eu la Commission
européenne annoncé l'ouverture d'une
enquête contre Amazon afin de vérifier
si les mesures mises en œuvre par ce ce
géant du du commerce en ligne pour
protéger les consommateurs notamment
contre les produits illégaux était bien
mis en œuvre et l'UE a lancé une salve
d'autres enquêtes ces dernières semaines
auprès de Facebook Instagram snapchat
TikTok ou encore YouTube la Commission
européenne elle veut s'assurer que ces
plateformes ont pris des mesures
nécessaires pour protéger les les
mineurs vous en parliez notamment sur la
santé sur la protection de leur santé
physique et mentale mais à ce stade il n
y a aucune sanction prévue par le le
régulateur européen mais au moins ça
donne un peu l'impression que l'Europe
prend un bras le corp le problème et
veut donner un petit tour de vis merci
beaucoup Jonathan pour ces informations
Alexandra borquio Fontain est-ce qu'on
peut dire que nous Européens on est les
mieux protégés finalement avec cette loi
est-ce que vous diriez ça alors c'est
difficile de pouvoir l'affirmer en tout
cas il y a un quique sur les derniers
textes qu'on a notamment étudié au Sénat
que ce soit le projet de loi sur le
numérique ou les différentes
propositions de loi donc cell sur la
majorité numérique c'est justement le
commissaire européen qui vient de de
s'exprimer a fait savoir que justement
il y avait certaines dispositions qui
empiétaient sur le droit européen qui
pouvait être en fait opposé à certaines
de nos dispositions donc pour l'instant
l'app iation de ces différents textes
qui ont été votés ces 6 derniers mois
sont suspendu donc pour l'instant voilà
on attend on attend notamment la loi
d'adu bientôt qui viendra peut-être
essayer un peu mieux de d'encadrer et de
réguler ses dispositions le DSA est à
mon sens une bonne chose maintenant il
faut que tout à chacun on puisse
réellement
pouvoir parvenir à ces applications
pouvoir dénoncer un contenu illicite moi
en tant que l'utilisatrice de ces
réseaux sociaux je trouve c'est encore
bien compliqué euh personne peut dire
aujourd'hui qu'on lutte contre le
cyberhcèlement que voilà qu'il n'y a pas
toute cette manipulation donc je pense
qu'il va falloir en tout cas encore
quelques années avant de se sentir
véritablement protégé Bruno Patino votre
avis c'est un réel progrès quand même
c'est un progrès maintenant c'est un
progrès très nettement parce qu'en plus
de ça dans les trois mesures qui ont été
très bien détaillées là on voit bien
qu'on va vers la responsabilité
algorithmique en fait et la compliance
après ce qu'on y arrivera maintenant le
le le le gros souci si Jea dire c'est
que les contenus illicdes c'est une
chose encore faut-il les définir mais on
sait mais il y a les contenus
préjudiciables et les contenus
préjudiciables ne sont pas forcément
illicites c'est-à-dire que une sorte de
désinformations des informations
rampantes des contextualisations voire
même des concours à un moment donné
biaiser des photos et cetera jusqu'à
quel point euh vous voyez ce je veux
dire c'est que individuellement ça peut
être préjudiciable à une personne ça
peut être licite mais leur leur
accumulation peut être préjudiciable
donc on est dans ce flou-l évidemment
c'est sur ce flou là que joue Elon Musk
en disant non non mais c'est liberté
d'expression donc prouvez-moi que c'est
totalement illicite suivant la loi
américaine ce qui est ce qui est
évidemment une définition extrêmement
restreinte de ce qui est illicite et
donc on est là-dedans mais
néanmoins enfin de mon point de vue il
faut reconnaître quand même que c'est un
pas important vers la responsabilité
algorithmique et vers l'alignement on va
dire
des du droit entre ce qui est en ligne
et ce qui est ce qui est dans le monde
réel enfin de mon point de vue en tout
cas ouais il y a il y a quand même une
question c'est la la question de la
modération est-ce qu'on n'est pas quand
même dans une vaste supercherie dans les
moyens mis en place par la plupart de
ses réseaux sociaux je vous propose
d'écouter le président de la République
Emmanuel Macron c'était la semaine
dernière lors d'un sommet sur la lutte
contre les contenus terroristes et et
extrémiste ça il donne des des chiffres
sur le nombre de modérateurs par réseau
social écoutons c'est sûr que quand on
me dit qu'il y a 52 modérateurs pour X
en langue française j'ai du mal à
considérer que le contenu est modéré
langue française pas la fr France il y A
330 millions de locuteurs en langue
française ces 52 personnes sont des
génies où ont beaucoup de travail il y
en a 226 pour
méta TikTok est pas là autour de la
table parce qu'on doit clarifier des
sujets de statut mais enfin ils en ont
déjà
687 je le dis pour créer de la
compétition de la bonne compétition
Alexandre borque Fontain là aussi on est
un peu dans l' puissance des état on va
pas obliger Elon Musk à embauchcher des
modérateurs enfin on voit bien quand
même la supercherie quand on voit le peu
de personnes qui sont embauché pour
faire de la modération au vu du nombre
d'utilisateurs on voit bien que ça sera
ça pourra pas être efficace euh il a
même annoncé la couleur musque en
transformant Twitter en X il veut que la
la la parole soit la plus libre possible
n'importe quelle parole oui oui tout à
fait mais de toute façon c'est
l'objectif évidemment des plateformes de
d'avancer cette liberté d'expression et
d'essayer de voilà de ne pas modérer les
contenus euh au terme pour la liberté
d'expression je crois qu'aujourd'hui il
faut véritablement taper du point sur la
table et imposer fortement et j'espère
que le DSA permettra ça h pour parvenir
à une à une une véritable régulation
alors les plateformes avancent toutes
pour se donner bonne conscience qu' m en
place C éta le cas lors de mes auditions
qu'ils ont tout un tas de dispositifs
pour protéger les mineurs pour
sensibiliser les parents parce qu'on a
pas parlé aujourd'hui en tant que
législateur on se doit de réguler les
contenus et je pense aussi que les
parents ont un rôle à jouer là-dedans
quand on on sait que 82 % des des
adolescents qui utilisent les réseaux
sociaux le font sans la présence des
parents ce qu'on peut comprendre on va
pas toujours être à côté de nos enfants
lorsqu'ils sont là-dessus mais ça on dit
long quand même sur
sur ce fossé aussi peut-être des fois
générationnel qui peut y avoir entre un
utilisateur et ses parents qui n'ont
absolument pas d'idée sur ce que leurs
enfants consultent Mathieu vous êtes
aussi intéressé à à la relation des des
femmes et des hommes politiques avec ces
réseaux sociaux bah oui parce qu'ils
font pas exception la règle et il n aura
fallu qu'une petite quinzaine d'années
pour que ce qui n'était qu'un gadget
devienne une drogue dure qui a
bouleversé à mes yeux en profondeur les
usages et les codes de la politique hein
au commencement tout était simple vous
vous souvenez Facebook venait de se
créer et puis les rares politiques qui
silanit le faisait surtout pour avoir
l'air moderne pour avoir l'air jeune
j'allais dire pour la blague mais très
vite ils se sont rendus compte des
potentialités immenses que leur offrait
ce nouvel outil s'adresser directement
au français sans le filtre des médias en
tout cas sans forcément le filtre des
médias fédérer interagir avec une
communauté sans le filtre du parti faire
campagne sans le filtre des marchés au
petit matin ou des meetings c'était la
belle affaire le problème c'est que ça
s'est pas vraiment passé comme prévu
est-ce que la la créature en quelque
sorte dépassé ses utilisateurs mais en
tout cas trois tendance lourde de fond à
mes yeux d'abord les réseaux sociaux ont
aboli l'échelle du temps politique sous
le dictate de l'urgence ils ont
transformé les élus en machine à réagir
à tout tout le temps tout de suite
aujourd'hui ce qui compte c'est d'abord
de prendre position en temps réel au
plus près de la nouvelle ou de
l'événement qu'ils subissent ils ont en
fait perdu la maîtrise de leur propre
agenda politique et puis l'essentiel
n'est plus forcément ce qu'on dit mais
d'être le premier à le dire et comme un
tweet chasselut comme tout se dit tout
se vaut bref leur parolle se banalis
second second effet les réseaux sociaux
ont bouleversé les codes du débat public
on en parlait tout à l'heure à propos de
la polarisation la multiplication des
formats courts quelques c'était quelques
centaines de caractères au début sur sur
Twitter c'est devenu quelques minutes à
peine sur sur pour les vidéos bah ça
s'embarrasse guerre de la pensée
complexe comme dirait l'autre la culture
du like pousse à à cliver les prises de
position au détriment de la nuance le
goût de la punchline ça a transformé
l'arène numérique en en ring voilà où
l'invecti a remplacer l'argument là pour
le coup l'essentiel c'est plus forcément
ce qu'on dit mais comment on le dit pour
monter dans les algorithmes et donc du
coup la vérité des faits passe au second
plan derrière l'affirmation d'une
opinion enfin troisème tendance les
réseaux sociaux ont finit par tendre au
politique un miroir déformant sur l'état
de l'opinion d'abord certains finissant
par penser que Twitter c'est la France
c'est quand même très très différent de
de ce qui se passe dans la vraie vie
parfois j'ose le dire et puis un miroir
déformant par rapport à leur propre
puissance aussi car si avoir une grande
communauté ben ça permet de briser le
mur du son médiatique souvent il faut le
dire ça se traduit pas forcément dans
les ur les likes sont pas des votes
sinon ce petit jeul zimour et Mélenchon
aurait fini président est-ce que c'est
un mouvement irréversible pour ces trois
tendances là à mes yeux oui en fait les
politiques ont tardé à comprendre que
les réseaux sociaux c'était pas
seulement une chambre des coméditiques
ça a été un impensé politique du coup on
a tardé à les appréhender on a tardé à
les réguler et moi je diffère un peu de
vous sur sur ce plan là je pense qu'il
est très compliqué de revenir en arrière
très difficile de mettre les bornes des
bornes en tout cas dans le champ
politique parce que toute tentative de
responsabilisation ou de modération est
vu évidemment comme une atteinte à la
liberté d'expression effectivement il y
a des politiques qui tombent on peut
dire ça des artistes aussi tiens Michel
Guérin bah c'est que à force de vouloir
réagir à tout et à n'importe quoi sur
les réseaux sociaux ça se ça peut se
transformer en piège il y a tellement
d'exemples quoi vous pensez je sais pas
des des prises de position politique on
l' vu récemment là depuis le 7 octobre
il y en a des des artistes qui sont
retrouvés en porte à fau qui donc oui
des sportifs de tout
oui oui mais je vois pas tellement je
pense pas que ce soit vraiment un
problème spécifique à l'art la réaction
sur les non non franchement je vois pas
mais le fait de de se passer du filtre
médiatique ça ça doit aussi vous vous
concerner vous interpeller c'est une de
parler directement à sa communauté oui
ou oui oui ça ça on peut en avoir oui
oui Taylor Swift est la grande
championne du monde de ça par exemple
pour la musique c'est fantastique
d'ailleurs mais comme elle est plutôt
pas mal je trouve et dans comment elle
s'exprime et ses idées ça donc on ne
voit pas trop mais on imaginait si elle
avait d'autres opinions ce que ça
pourrait faire mais je je crois pas
vraiment une spécificité des par rapport
aux sportifs ou d'autres ou par rapport
à ce que vous dites NON de de la culture
Bruno Patino sur la simplification c'est
la tendance elle est pas nouvelle c'est
vrai que les les tweets c'est le c'est
le la dernière étape d'une
simplification de la ça peut être la
dernière étape d'une simplification de
la pensée politique d'une certaine façon
c'est une oralisation général en fait
c'est-à-dire que si on reprend enfin je
mentionne un peu dans le livre mais si
on on regarde un peu la structure du
débat en fait ces réseaux c'est ça le
paradoxe alors de moins en moins avec
TikTok ou ailleurs parce que l'image est
à nouveau là mais mais x enfin Twitter
parce que personne l'appelle x encore en
réalité vous donne vous donne l'illusion
d'une discussion écrite et en réalité
c'est l'oralisation de l'écrit donc
c'est une oralisation générale
maintenant sur moi je suis assez
d'accord avec ce ce qui a été dit par
grroissand mais si on regarde bien au
niveau des politiques vous avez deux
choses en réalité c'està-dire que vous
avez des politiques qui se servent et et
et souvent ils le font qui se servent
des réseaux pour créer une communauté
oui vraiment donc j'ai mes mes mes mes
suivants et cetera donc c'est l'aspect
communautaire et là effectivement les
outils de méta que ce soit Instagram
Facebook ou ailleurs sont utiles et donc
on voit bien qu'aujourd'hui être présent
quelque part dans le public c'est créer
des communautés plus ou moins solides
plus ou moins polarisé ou autre était
leur Swift d'ailleurs avec les swiftties
c'est la plus grande communauté
aujourd'hui vivante active sans doute
qui est absolument extraordinaire et
donc les politiques comme les autres
créent leur communauté sur un thème ou
sur autour de leur personne et puis
c'est pesé sur l'agenda et donc ça
c'était plutôt Twitter c'est le fait de
se dire on sait très bien qu'en étant
présent sur X ou sur Twitter à un moment
donné je vais imposer un thème dans SAF
que l'agenda les rattrape c'est ce que
disait Mathieu c'estàd que ils sont
obligés de réagir tout le temps et à
tout oui mais mais en plus de ça on voit
qu'aujourd'hui avec la pardon je vais le
dire comme ça la semiestruction par elon
musx de son propre outil je ne suis pas
sûr que le poids de X ou de de Twitter
dans dans dans le fait de faire l'agenda
continue après si on regarde les
histoires électorales de ces dernières
années on a pratiquement des élections
par réseau c'est-à-dire que vous avez
vous avez l'élection de Trump qui est
l'élection Facebook bolsonaro c'est
l'élection WhatsApp euh on voit qu'on a
eu une tentative là avec des élections
TikTok en Argentine en ce moment ce qui
est en train de se passer vous avez sans
doute pour la première fois ce genre de
chos donc on voit que si vous voulez le
mais mais encore une fois c'est c'est
c'est c'est inexorable d'une certaine
façon que que que que la discussion
globale la conversation globale les
représentations globales par passent par
ce genre d'outils c'est pour ça que le
fonctionnement de ces outils est
absolument essentiel allez il nous reste
quelques minutes le temps àiler beaucoup
trop vite on va terminer vraiment sur
précisément sur le thème de votre livre
je vais donner cette submersion cette
profusion d'image et de et de contenu
culturel un premier chiffre tiens chaque
jour c'est le patron d'Universal musque
qui qui le dit 100000 nouvelles chansons
sont proposées sur les plateformes ça
fait 37 millions de chansons en plus par
an ça c'était des chiffres de septembre
2022 de mémoire et c'est CIN fois plus
élevé par rapport à 2018 ce cette
démonstration là on peut la faire dans
tous les domaines culturels dans tous
les domaines he sur une plateforme de
musique vous avez entre 80 et 100
millions de titres disponibles vous avez
sur quelque chose comme Netflix entre
31000 pour la France 41000 programmes
disponibles si vous vous êtes en vidéo
et sur Youtube il vous faut 30000 ans il
vous faudrait 30000 ans pour regarder
les nouveautés d'une année mais mais
mais ceci on pourrait dire c'est
formidable mais ça a modifié nos choix
en fait même dans ce que disait Michel
raconé tout à l'heure non c'est pas
ouais c'est c'est-à-dire qu'en fait
maintenant on est choisi plus qu'on
choisit ouis reste à savoir si on est
choisi par un moment donné un flux parce
que les choses vont vers nous où on est
choisi par un flux algorithmique est
calculé à un moment donné donc toute la
modif
si vous voulez de de notre vie
culturelle mais même politique ou autre
fait que de plus en plus on est on est
d'une façon ou d'une autre passif face à
nos choix c'est-à-dire que les choses
vont vers nous on les reçoit on est
informé on s'informe de moins en moins
on pense qu'on est informé on est
diverti on est en rencontre alors ça
provoque des de nouvelles choses qui
sont pas toutes négatives mais ça
modifie beaucoup les choses et du coup
ça reporte
totalement totalement la la la question
sur deux ch chose d'abord quand quand on
est face à C submersion je le crois et
ça se ça se d'ailleurs ça s'étudie qu'il
y a un sentiment de fatigue qui peut
arriver donc on va dire bon c'est pas
grave si vous avez la fatigue musicale
quand c'est la fatigue informationnelle
qui touche un Français sur deux c'est un
une dégradation de l'espace public et un
retrait de l'espace public où on délègue
le choix à une formule mathématique et
dans ces cas-là il vaut mieux savoir
comment elle fonctionne parce que à un
moment donné on en revient sur ce qu'on
disait sur les r service on rient si on
sait pas comment ça fonctionne et bien
d'une façon ou d'une autre on est choisi
on pense être plus libre parce qu'on a
plus d'options et en fait on l' de moins
en moins parce qu'on est choisi par une
formule et ça a toujours été le cas
pardon les algorithmes qui euh au début
j'avais l'impression moi que les réseaux
sociaux il y avait une forme de
sérindipité c'estàd qu'on on trouvait
dans son fil des choses complètement
anecdotiques ou auquel on on sur lesquel
on aurait jamais cliqué est-ce que dès
le début ça a été pensé comme ça dès le
début les algorithmes sont faits pour
une seule chose c'est évidemment rendre
le plus rentable possible les réseaux
qui l'utilisent ils n'ont pas
d'idéologie particulière ils ont juste
un ils ont juste un objet objectif
augmenter le chiffre d'affaires pour
augmenter le chiffre d'affaires il faut
que vous passiez le plus de temps
possible sur sur le réseau donc ils ont
été faits depuis le début pour faire
passer le plus de temps possible
maintenant c'est le temps ou la marge
donc on voit bien que dans les
algorithmes de de de de recommandation à
un moment ou un autre avant régulation
on a les mises en avant de certains
produits qui sont liés à la plateforme
elle-même ou autres qui sont produits
juste réagir sur la la diffusion des des
plateformes cinématographiques ou
musical moi je trouve aussi c'est une
bonne chose cette offre culturelle Mo
prfère regarder mon programme
cinématographique en jeu et sans pub
donc je trouve aussi qu'il y a quand
même des effets positifs et sur comme
vous parlez tout à l'heure de
l'utilisation des réseaux sociaux pour
les politiques par excusez-moi d'être
excusez-moi d'être d'être d'être
concerné par ça mais je trouve que c'est
une bonne manière de faire connaître
notre travail et ça n'empêche absolument
pas le travail de fond qu'on peut faire
au Sénat c'est juste de
raconter
trés ça se voit bien dans le livre comm
un des gros problèmes c'est que c'est on
le pensait pas c'est que ça accroit
énormément les inégalités devant l'offre
culturelle c'estàdire que vous avez quoi
tout en haut de plus en plus et enfin le
peu d'œuvres je prend la littérature par
exemple parce que là c'est quand même
des secteurs qui étaient peut-être le
moins touchés par le numérique et vous
avez de moins en moins de livres qui
explosent et qui qui qui accumule les
les lectures vous avez tout un ventre
mou qui a disparu et ça c'est le plus
grave c'est vous avez des livres qui se
vendaient à 20 30 40000 exemplayen qui
disparu la moyenne a disparu il avait
des paquets les maisons d'édition sont
complètement flippé en ce moment par ça
il y a plus ça et ça c'est dramatique et
vous avez tout en bas des dizaines voir
des centaines de milliers de
livres qui sont vendus entre 7 20 30
exemplaires maximum dans le livre on dit
la moitié à moins de 12 exemplaires pour
la Grande-Bretagne voilà la réalité elle
est dramatique et la submersion vous
pensez avoir le choix en tout mais en
fait quand vous regardez statistiquement
c'est ce qu'on appelle ça donne le
winner Tex c'està-dire le gagnant
emporte toute la mise et en réalité on
pensait au début la longue tr si vous
souvenez que tout le monde avait sa
chance et en réalité plus vous avez et
moi aussi je me réjouis d'une offre et
d'un accès mais d'un accès j'allais dire
quasiment universel mais encore faut-il
piloter l'organe du choix et c'est là où
ça s'est déplacé ouis et pour les jeunes
artistes enfin on parler de musique AR
compliqué parce que ils sont à la fois
ils disent rien parce qu'ils sont
contents parce que ils ont un accès
comme personne comme ils pouvaient pas
l'avoir avant oui vous avez plein de
chanteurs qui à des moments avant même
de faire un disque sont très connus ou
des concerts et puis vont faire c'était
jamais le cas avant il y avait toujours
l' le 10 puis après la scène et Cera ça
complètement renversé mais personne ne
dit rien parce que il y a toujours cette
cette illusion c'est comme gagner au
loto hein c'est pareil mais en revanche
c'est rare ici et qu'en fait c'est une
fausse démocratie c'est c'est une fausse
croyance et donc on narrive pas à à à
faire enfin ce que dit dans son livre
Bruno Patino c'est tous les études le
montent déjà depuis de 3 ans qui on qui
monent et et c'est dramatique moi je
pense qu' on on n'a pas encore vu tous
les effets que ça va avoir sur ce que
vous croyez être une offre culturelle
merveilleuse merci beaucoup merci à tous
je rappelle Bruno Patino le titre de ce
livre submersion qui est donc publié aux
éditions grassa je vous dis à bientôt
sur sur public scè a noté que l'invité
de la matinale demain sera Agnès firman
le baudau la ministre délégué chargé de
l'organisation territoriale et des
professions de santé elle sera face à
Orian mansin à 8h du matin belle
soirée
[Musique]